hello my name is jimmy lin i'm the
founder president and rare genomics
institute today we're going to be
talking on a session called implementing
clinical research whole exome and genome
for diagnosis of very diseases in a
local perspective what we are as we are
a nonprofit organization that helps
patients for the rare diseases to be
able to access cures what we have done
as a first step has been doing genome
sequencing and we're now sort of doing
processes in order to start to do model
organisms and to look for drugs and to
do is the subsequent functional analysis
that is necessary afterwards so I'm
going to talk a little bit about what
we've been able to learn through our
sites on which we have mostly in the US
but we're also i'm in countries such as
Singapore Malaysia Australia Israel and
the experiences from using who works on
the whole genome table to help these
patients a little bit of my background
um I did my MD PhD at Johns Hopkins and
we're trained and and with that
background what my work has been was we
were the first to solve the cancer home
to determine the cancer exone so we
initially did it for breast and
colorectal cancers and then eventually
we were able to do similar separate
studies with pancreatic cancer in real
blastoma does all this work was mostly
sort of at that cusp of next generation
but this was really I'm ability to start
even looking at you know what was
possible I'm through exome sequencing
and eventually were able to actually
look at my job I stoma and also sis
build susceptibility and and this was
you know a lot of the background for
which should i bring to this but then my
would life was dramatically changed
after I finished my PhD doing all this
working
cancer genomics I met her family this is
not their picture but it represents it
was a slow little Indian family and
little boy that was sick they cannot
figure out what was wrong travel all the
way from a buffalo all the way down from
upstate New York to Hopkins to be able
to find the diagnosis but nobody could
help them and and at that time those
were the first studies were and out of
university of washington where exome
sequencing was starting to be used to
determine causes of diseases and we
think you know what what if we took all
the experiences that we had in cancer
and start using it for excellent
sequencing for very diseases so that was
been really the start um sort of our
creation of our nonprofit to be able to
implement and help rare disease patients
access exome sequencing access different
centers to be able to do that how many
analysis done but also now we're
definitely sort of expanding as exome
sequencing is now a more more available
clinically and we covered by insurance
we now see the knees sort of shifting
downstream to be able to figure out what
those genes do and how to find potential
therapies and drugs or how to study the
function of those genes on to be able to
help so for those who don't know this is
sort of a quick plot and generalized
block of rare diseases in general there
are some diseases that have very high
prevalence and but there's a long tail
diseases that have very little
prevalence in fact there's over seven
over 7,000 different diseases in this
long tail I'm often considered new
labeled as rare disease in the u.s. is
less than two hundred thousand patients
affected but it's very hard to be able
to solve and figure out ways to help all
seven thousand diseases and affects over
300 million patients worldwide so this
is actually a pretty large disease
burden and to be able to start sort of
making an impact is a sort of a
difficult problem
so because it's so sort of diverse and
it spread up and do so many different
diseases right now the vast majority of
rare diseases have don't have a research
program specifically to help them many
of the no Vaseline you don't have an
advocacy cube no foundation support so
most of the families are sort of on
their own trying to figure out what's
wrong I'm now even with your
proliferation of exome sequencing and
clinical exome sequencing most of these
families even if they're able to get a
diagnosis you know really struggle to be
able to help their child that's in need
so that's theirs
and five percent of these diseases that
have any treatment or therapy and this
one is a pretty serious problem leaving
the ninety-five percent of the 7000
diseases or 300 million people don't
have a mechanism to have any type of
therapy so that's that all they see is a
great burden not only to think of as a
population level but also but you know
every single one of these kids I'm have
faces and have names and have families
and and that's why it sort of is very
very important to figure out ways I'm to
be able to help so this is why we
created our Institute I'm completely
volunteer run by people all over the US
and the world to be able to figure out
ways to be able to help these patients
so I'm going to walk through one example
of a patient and also then talk about
more in general been in terms of lessons
we've been able to learn from that so
let's go walk through one example um
this is this is Robert um one of our
first patients he was born healthy but
then around age one he all of a sudden
sort of lost control of his muscles and
I was unable to feed and had a dramatic
clinical decline um so so they started
in a rush in the hospital and started
testing it tried to figure out what was
wrong and you know 14 years later over
millions of dollars later Robert still
really hasn't didn't have answers in
terms of figure out what was wrong with
him and still no group that belongs to
to help them and they go you know try
and place a place where to figure out
what's wrong with rubber but the very
fact is it's the system is very hard to
help Rob when we and you know this is
sort of two years ago when there was
very little access to clinical
sequencing and we started two sided
figure out how do we do this then so the
first thing that we do is provide sort
of the technology and of course work and
is talking about exome and genome
sequencing we all sort of know
for diseases like that using whole
genome horse on sequencing is
potentially very effective as a picture
and inside of a scanner to be able to to
map not only sort of robbers genome but
his parents she known to be able to find
the gene of interest then we found
people who are able to do this research
so I commend him for were many many
centers in the US and also in the world
including Harvard Yale and Hopkins and
we approach researchers were willing to
help patients like bees and able to
provide their existing pipelines and
networks and to be able to help and
lastly although there are some funding
for some sequencing a lot of our
patients don't fit into the traditional
plans are existing so we want to make it
sort of last week as we are expanding
that all the patients are able to access
email without without funding so we have
an online platform which is a
crowdfunding platform where patients
themselves are able to raise the funds
are needed for the different research
projects I'm starting now which is
mostly now sort of based on like some
sequencing so fun for Robert I think
this is sort of standard prices there
are excellent sequencing between seven
to ten thousand dollars and they were
able to raise it from from friends and
family and and this you know they do not
have to sort of fit into an existing
funding mechanism to be able to help so
what we have then is a team of
scientists and researchers at different
universities along with their community
providing the funding for this to be
able to help patients like Robert so
today we actually are excited to report
that we were you know are able to sort
of find out the gene of interest is pure
it's a specific PR cures team gene and
Robert actually because of that therapy
is now starting to be able to use
assistive devices due to the diagnosis
or was important is for Robert to be
diagnosed in terms of knowing that his
effectiveness is a [ __ ] is a must learn
fact an unnecessary cognitive so Robert
for the first time is now communicating
with his family to you know with this or
diagnosis and be able to
move on in terms of what the family is
able to get and today you know of course
though there has been a dramatic cure
yet for Robert but the next step now
we're actively studying his gene there's
there's a team of scientists in Canada
as well as in washington st. Louis are
now looking at the gene that sort of
affecting him and we are actually in the
middle of starting to do some functional
studies and the goal is to not only do
the sequencing has had a full pipeline
to go to help and be able to fund every
step of the way we have our genome
sequencing becomes more and more
prevalent when more people who have sort
of gene sequence but then the functional
annotation is still not yet there yet so
there is going to be a lot of work to be
able to figure out what these genes do
we've have an amazing for partnerships
from a lot of different companies we
were able to support providing with us
funding or reagents oh I know model
organisms to help as well as you know
our story actually our motto sort of
bottom of research has has actually been
able to garner a lot of press attention
so that a lot of patients would have
come to us as we sort of figure out ways
to help these patients with rare
diseases so far I think about get
mentioned we're mostly right now in the
US but we have sites in Spain and Israel
and we're starting to do work also so in
India and Australia and then really just
sort of provided this infrastructure if
there is a need to be able to either
raise of funding or help them look
interpretation and everything that's
sort of needed for these projects so
that's just sort of sort of quick intro
as I come into the area where what is it
that we sort of learn from all these
different sites and all these different
projects in terms of you know the
implementation of exome sequencing
firstly I'm there there's a there's
discussion of sort of participant
selection so if you see this graph here
I'm on the x-axis it's goes from group
decision to individual decision on the
y-axis is clinical research so in excess
is is how is it that someone is the
terminal whether they're a good
candidate for sequencing or not so there
are some centers that are have sort of
large groups that decide and well as you
know as we more more more clinical you
see where the star is you want really
one clinician to be able to sort of make
the decision to think you know it's an
appropriate test on the y-axis here it
goes from research to clinical as you
know everything in sort of startups in
the research criteria and eventually you
implement it in terms of clinical
context and there's there's two
developments here whether you develop it
starting from a group decision clinical
testing or you go from no group doing
research and make an individual testing
they need criteria development so
ultimately what are sort of the criteria
that that fits especially you want to
test a criteria there are three specific
sort of criteria so sweetly implement
and and this is sort of Kim's will be
generalized through a lot of things very
important for patient criteria right you
need to knowing the phenotyping is going
to be very very important terms of
looking a little history of illness like
your previous testing especially whether
they've done microarray testing on
whether their their phenotype news is
something that I've paid sort of
existing or genetic type family
characteristics is also going to be very
important whether the pedigree is
available the motive hairs as most of
that user suspect as well as sort of
population characteristics um whether
they have much similar families or known
syndromes so these this criterias makes
it in order to go to determine and
having these criteria then allows us to
be you know use it as a clinical testing
tool no longer the cars are these groups
to be able to do that
then in terms of you know depth of
coverage how deep do you want to sort of
cover as you sequence and here on extra
care I sort of look at single gene
traditionally all the way to whole
genome and then the coverage on is on
the y-axis going for a sort of roughly
honest or ten to a thousand and
traditional testing obviously has done
very deep coverage with Sanger
sequencing and genetics panel was as you
move more and with cancer you want to
have very high sequencing so even if you
use next-gen you know having these high
coverage is going to be a important but
as you sort of move move towards and
sort of genetics as you sort of see
little bit green duct and so the
coverage doesn't know I think for for
most of our sites and the coverage is
anything between 60 on the lower side to
sort of 90 x in terms of coverage from
genetics whereas for for cancer on the
excellent side we you know we can
inflict pure sample you can deflect them
but I really you wanted to put a much
much higher because hydrogenating cancer
before each fortune for for genetics
perspective the recovered really you
know doesn't have you know I'm in terms
of death could be a could be lower and
that that allows for you know you to be
able to put us or a lot of these samples
on one run especially when you're doing
so trios our family to be able to do
that so I would enters the sample prep
on what are the things that are sort of
different sites do and here you see you
know the bluffs here there's the two
sort of specific ways whether you want
to do amplicon sequin amplicons or
methods or it'll capture methods and
then what do you want to do X on one
panel because did it in sort of the
nature of these sort of sequencing
diagnostic Odysseys more more methods
have sort of been thinking more in terms
of sort of using a larger exome would be
able to look at all unknown diseases
however if there are sort of specific
panels for example cardiomyopathy or
hearing loss or related can you know
define panels and that is possible as
well so for four panels amplicon systems
rather sort of no one
but there was a fluid I nampa seeing
rain dance and the part of these
applicants is you know you can be able
to produce smaller quantities and the
problem is it's a little harder to look
at copy number alternative housing
number changes but that's sorta less of
a concern within sort of a genetics as
opposed to cancer for frat zone there's
whether you know the capture that user
exim is mostly you know we used nibble
general shooting agilent or most of our
sites actually so to use the agilent
based technologies but then as more and
more discoveries are made it is possible
that then you know panels can be
developed will be that's able to not
only sort of happen do the whole thing
and eventually the clinical testing can
be done for specific small the types of
sort of capture sets these are some
examples whether Emory near baylor
developing smaller capture sets but
that's really in terms of early stages
of these genetic testing you don't know
what to capture so starting with exxon
was probably the best way to do it but
as you know better and you have a
phenotype where you have suspected genes
then capturing with a panel under
suddenly would be a way to sort to go
there in terms of the technology I think
you know most people on these calls
would would understand that you know
there's been a tremendous growth in
terms of sequencing on whether it's sort
of first gen sequencing of the Sanger
and then second gen sequencing all these
companies of course sort of complete
have been purchased and helical it's not
a sort of viable but the main ones I
think like everybody does this is mostly
based on sort of alumina technologies
like sewing and the torn based on
suitable live technology most of our
sites have been using Morse or alumina
based technologies but of course we know
that there is sort of on slotter third
generation sequencing that sort of
coming on board although most of them
have not been really sort of
commercialize you yet but we're sort of
excited about these new technologies
especially for rare diseases on whether
it's not something like a new virus
banana poor and this one we really would
as it becomes water adopted and it
becomes easier on clinical testing that
you know can be sort of distributed and
then fast so I sort of Informatics how
are sort of the pipelines are used in
terms of Informatics the the the the
rough outline of Informatics are
starting from alignment to Baron calling
to filtering annotation to clinical
reporting so some of the shown here is
all the different sort of permutations
whether it's sort of done in the cloud
or a local I think most of our sites is
sort of you see that sort of in the
orange sort of the local locally sort of
done the alignment and Baron calling
whether it's noble craft no bloodline or
bwa with alignment and in the Sam tools
and jtk most likely I'm JTP 1644 variant
calling um so that's actually mostly
sort of done locally and it's able to
reduce a lot of the file size and and
sort of a lot of the computation of
power fittest but locally although some
of our partners have been able to do it
in a cloud but most of them have used to
be able to sort of do that locally then
the second step then is is what we have
seen is actually that stuff is local but
then the later with the filtering and
annotation sometimes it's done in the
cloud well some do it locally but you
know something uses sort of tools such
as you know ingenuity or golden helix to
be able to do that no many also do it
locally and just sort of using simple
scripts to be able to do that so that's
what a one model where you split up
between between the Devere and
colonization the filtering stage at how
it's done and then you know there are
systems wrote it combined it to which is
shown a purple and ultimately there are
ones where it goes all the way to
clinical reporting the challenge of
clinical reporting is that you can't
just sort of you know make a reckon you
know look at what's the output in
specific to say that it needs to be
databases that are known to be you know
verified in clinical context the data
which you report because they're going
to map it upon clinically really has the
databases building human data and levels
of competence you know you
I need to be able to specify a lot so so
there's that extra step with clinical
reporting is a very very critical step
while those sort of shown us a small
step here this is one of the largest
barriers right now there's a lot of
sites can't do sequencing very simply
and can do the lineman calling and you
know to figure out depending on the
genetic profile you know what are the
top jeans but to turn that into the
clinical reporting is sort of the main
hurdle so how they sort of filtering
done and i think i think the pipelines
are sort of very similar between you and
all our different sites but this is sort
of a general model between the different
sites of how it's done so whether it's
usually what happened is taking all the
vantage how you have taking the known
variants I'm to sort of remove this so
that you may have the rare variants so
whether this is using sort of more
public databases are curated databases
of known variants suggestion of Seattle
snip or unload cosmic or to be able to
take those and some people are able to
sort annotate with known slimmed
locations and be able to annotate that
then this next step is going to be very
important terms of the genetic and this
is where a larger the filtering sort of
occurs and or it's important to have
family members to people do that and a
lot of the filtering occurs in and mr.
the quality of genetics then one size
filter than the annotation and the
database to be able to do that is going
to be very very critical of how you're
able to do that so whether people ugh
tmd or you know some other types of
databases you'll be able to do that but
to be honest they're still a great
opportunity for someone to develop i
really call the clinical annotation
database for this or whatever something
like nih using cream bar then you there
are you know different prediction
algorithms that people need to use
whether it is something you know basis
such as an anavar or sift and polyphen
to sort of predict and and so the jury's
really out of you know how effective
these are but I think it's helpful I
think for most of our site stone to be
able to sort of use this type of it from
as they're thinking about it now
ultimately they're sort of manual step
of curation a selection and to be able
to fit whether the phenotype is similar
to potentially similar to what's what's
predicted by the genetic sequence so
this sort of a general felue strategy of
different sites have sort of slight
modifications of this one but but in
general this you know is a pretty good
strategy to be able to do that in terms
of then there's a big question of sort
of how then it's sort of reported out
and I draw this sort of honor two
accesses on the excesses where it's how
open or closed the system is and then on
the y-axis is going from leashes your
clinical so on the very very bottom the
quadrant wears clothes and research
that's where traditional research has
lies where you know it's done in a
research environment and you don't sort
of report it back they can go a little
bit up you see that there's our area of
clinical research were some of that
information is relayed and you see
there's a sort of arrow there drawing
past the X and Y axis is some some sites
then you know do the sequencing in a
research context and then validate using
Sanger clear then be able to report for
more open systems um you know you have
companies who like the Personal Genome
Project China and me I'm variable to
sort of you know provided all the data
of course the most extreme is no
personal genome project that that's able
to provide all the data in an open
source manner and and you know proper
consenting and all that pgp does is able
to do that but with on the other
quadrant on where its clinical and open
this is where you know ultimately where
everybody's were looking towards you
know you have clinical labs and academic
universities such as failure in Emory
UCLA or your company's a GTI example
vitae to be able to sort of report a
smaller subset um let you know and then
only if you ask you able to get a little
larger data but but in terms of the sort
of data in terms of I wrote these are so
two companies of research panel
but a PG DX where it's sort of a ver
able to provide sort of a lot more sort
of information and more and more
companies now are providing this model
where they're returning a lot more data
and only only you know the potentially
could be over gene the potential you may
give the entirety of the data and of
course this slide is very very
controversial of what to report back and
whether how to report back them
incidental findings and how much the
patient should really have so the next
question that if it's sort of really
done as clinical sequencing of how his
reimbursements done it in it is it is it
possible there and what are their cause
so this is just a sort of weak graph of
the cost and reimbursement and of course
so then in the past sequencing you know
I have you know such as sort of braga
test could be five to seven thousand
dollars myriad or and just sequencing
and it's still between you know under
10k and then there's some panels are
over 10k so even just for once one gene
I want a series of jeans for one disease
it could easily go past ten k um but
then other diagnostic is clinically you
know where there's a CT scan or MRI can
also be you know they sort of fall in
that range as well and then you sort of
think about you want to sort of compare
to a week at I see in the NICU for a
child that's born in NICU easily for
over ten thousand dollars or a year of
orphan disease jokes so when we're
telling real people who're reimbursing
and paying for this the amount that
usually right now for sure exome
sequencing around so seven two thousand
dollars in this context you know I
actually sort of often is a cost savings
and if you're able to sort of minimize
in a hospital stay or minimum wise use
of you know be able to target the use of
these drugs this is actually a strong
case to be made for pairs and to be able
to provide reimbursement there
so as we think about sort of all these
technologies this is a very very
important slide is it's it's not sort of
you know simple and clear-cut into sort
of input the sequencing outcomes the
answer and I don't sort of walk through
this size for a little bit sort of in
depth in terms of thinking about
cabinets and what are sort of the
barriers for this to be implemented on a
large large scale and all the hospital
centers for for insurance to reimburse
it and for this to be a largely a
adopted test and what are the things
that's preventing right number one is
there's really sufficient power of
annotation so how or and it's so
sometimes there is not enough families
there's too few of the same disease or
when you find the gene the annotation
isn't there so there really a sort of a
lack of databases that's able to you
know annotate every single position
every single gene in the human genome
and we still don't know a lot of what
the genome does so even if you find but
you know a large panel of mutations at
different aspects you really don't know
whether you know your conjecture and
that's all it is after your filtering
I'm is true or not you need two
removable families and it requires a lot
of more information for that to be use
there so that's just you know databases
and whether that's sort of sufficient
secondly sort of be able to able to
sufficiently covered the genome so
there's sort of a lot of knowledge rocks
for the first exon hi GC content and how
that it's very hard to cover and
companies like you know how personnel is
have been able to start solve those
problems but still coverage is going to
be issue and if your gene of interest a
mutation of interest is not correctly
covered whether it's sort of miss better
capture protocol or whether your
informatics is you know unable to sort
of call the position you you can
sequence all you want and you'll be
missing that so that coverage is going
to be important
number three I think right now the
pipelines are very strong for single
nucleotide mutations and Sigma current
changes but not still really developing
in terms of copying them up calming
never alterations translocations and
other types of unchecked sort of changes
there so if your if your pipeline is
good i just sort of capturing you know
smbs you may potentially be missing
there and as well as those i just
included sort of in dells so you know
many many different algorithms be able
to try to be able to call in though
whether it's real large Intel wrong
Intel and that that's still an important
thing to serve you know be able to take
in consideration as you're doing these
sort of sequencing methods for the war
if you just do XO of course you need to
look at and sean's obscure and I out
stuff I mean intronic regions that
you'll miss based on that so how you
designed to study in your hypotheses
before that furthermore even if you have
the perfect coverage even you have the
your gene of interest in it it's leven
there there are potentially sort of UDP
or there is an immortal jeans or mosaic
model mosaicism so looking at sort of
potential sort of non-mendelian genetics
is you know you need to consider that or
even non genetics whether it's an
epigenetic factor or microbiome so all
this room is sooo into work must mean to
take into consideration to be able to do
that so really good sort of filtering
even sort of a priority to make sure
that this is thought to be a genetic
test them genetic disease it's going to
be very important that's what sort of
talk about those criteria I'm to be made
whether in a few contacts or individual
contacts lastly i have actually many
many more but it's just some of the
status even in the algorithms are
currently are still being developed
right whether alignment you know what is
sort of good alignment as we have longer
reads you can have better alignment but
but that's still um they're little
better programs be able to it there
variant calling i think there's a lot of
I know with what Sam chosen JDK but
there's other initiatives you know I
brought be able to do group variant
calling them my new algorithms be able
to do that and currently they're still
you know missing a lot of sort of
variance in different ways especially
when when they're sort of sequencing
errors or so lower sort of sample sizes
so so the tags that you fine arts are a
lower number in terms of coverage and
how are you going to be able to sort of
call a variant in their context so so
this is sort of a quick sort of view of
what excellency causing how it's going
to be effective or not this is a hype
cycle that's used in technology circles
it's called the corona heights title and
we're in the beginning there sort of
technology's inventor then there's a lot
of peak of inflated expectations and I
think we're sort of at this moment I
we're actually maybe go through the
trust top of the illusion that we know
that and a lot of diseases are not going
to be all figured out but they're still
in a lot of excellent products I'm being
done but then I think as we are able to
really sort of nuance and finesse and
knowing what we're looking for we're
gonna go up that slope of enlightenment
in terms of and implement this tissue
the plateau of productivity to be able
to do there but the things this is this
is all just really the beginning of
these methods of sort of sequencing
sequencing can only sort of do a very
limited amount and these are some of the
technologies then we in-house are
starting to sort of partner what we're
doing I'll be able to validate and in
this validation is going to be
incredibly important in terms of
figuring out what these mutations mean
and what these gene mean and and to
really bring value up to the sequencing
so for example I think picture here is
shown of a mouse model so lot of
organisms be able to recapitulate under
the disease phenotype and and to really
understand like whether it's really that
gene that's sort of causing that and
we're working with companies like
taconic and be able to sort of do that
secondly there's there's going to be a
top there's a picture of a microwave but
using other modalities it's going to be
important or whether you are using RNA
seek to see whether the mutation is
actually expressed in the tissue of
interest or looking with proteomics
where they're sort of functional changes
in the protein whether its ability to
metabolize or what their support for
lady phosphorylate to be a one using
higher throughput functional genomics
methods and to be able to annotate might
understand the effects of these mutation
this is going to be a shame extremely
important to be able to do that in
addition I think picture here was sort
of put with a gene is there's going to
be need for sort of drugs drug screening
so whether is even if you know the
function what are some existing drugs
potentially through repositioning
repurposing that could help for the
famous cases for example with the
berries it's sort of missing your
transmitter and that's able to provide
sure I'm very effectively there so drug
repurposing it's going to be a very very
important aspect there without having
for rare diseases to go through those
long pipe lines with common disease we
will do that the next one here is sort
of read his terms of growing cell lines
so without having to sort of do the
actual experimentation on the person
having the cell lines and then to be
able to do it experimental that for
individuals not be important so with the
development of technology such as the
IPS stem cell technology where you know
you can test these sort of existing
drugs and these cell lines or understand
the function in each cell line until use
that as a sensitive system and to be
able to do that and lastly I just will
show a general picture you see a little
scientist wedding of a peeker is that
there is an entire sort of large amount
of functional study that it's going to
be important as well as so leveraging
all these additional technologies model
organisms and to be able to understand
so we are really really at the very tip
of using sort of genomics for
interpretation especially with all
all these clinical exome sequencing
that's done by companies it's still very
much sort of very hard to be able to
definitive on to say oh this is what
exactly is able to cause it so as more
and more of these for the functional
annotation is done there there is an
ability then to to add to those
databases for further you know
prediction and functional annotation and
and then that the database of
interpretation is going to be very very
important and having that is critical
that infrastructure is critical in that
database critical for exome sequencing
to be really adopted on a wide scale as
opposed to sort of in just as a
researcher contact so here an original
mix r and r sort of a small nonprofit
consortium where we will continue fight
really the 25 million patients are out
there I'm all looking for answers all
looking for diseases and for us to be
able to help us help them with diagnosis
and help them with the subsequent and
our annotation and and ultimately i
think these parents don't give up until
they find cures and we seek to be to
come alongside them every step of the
way so there are a lot of people that
have been sort of critical when I would
work over 100 scientists working with
our GI including on the left years this
is some of our core members and and I'm
on the left our core members and on the
right log or our expert panels were able
to mount provide sequencing
understanding but also in terms of what
after sequencing intensive functional
annotation and it most importantly what
I think parents patients and their
communities to be able to sort of do
this and a partner with us on that so
thank you that was sort of a a quick
overview of what we do and the mechanism
do that your interest in czar
collaborating or size or use a question
such as my email feel free
to contact me there so if you want
continued education credits this is the
website to be able to do that and now
open for questions
so looking at some of the questions one
of the first questions is how exact is
the genome landscaper human breast
cancer for understanding disease if we
understand it why do we fail sorry maybe
I that once again so this is from noble
University who asks how exactly is our
Gonzaga the genome my clan soooo breast
cancer for understanding disease if you
understand it what if we if we
understand why we fail to act for
precise diagnosis or treatment if you
don't understand it what's the benefit
research so the question is no the dark
matter of DNA and whether the sort of
action matters for breast cancer so in
terms of cancer are our initial sort of
sequencing is is actually very
interesting seeing that all cancers are
very going to be very very different and
and all and what's going to be important
is to be understand the context of field
is to understand the context of these
sort of heterogeneity and based on what
the mutations they have then be able to
sort of a sign the correct medications
and therapies for that and the big thing
is there there is no current sort of a
lot of the targeted therapies are still
much sort of in development so as more
more you know different cancers are
sequencing whether through the TCGA or
international consortium all these
different studies will be able to better
appreciate on the heterogeneity person a
person as well as in person to then
start to be able to sort of the quote
you know the tailor made for therapies
for different sort of cancers so the
landscape is not uniform it is not one
and same it's going to be different for
different people and us for us to be
able to start characterizing this on a
large scale so that we can understand
the individual variations it's going to
be very very
important so there's a lot of very great
work especially in sort of breast cancer
to do that but all for all cancers as
more and more different tissue types are
characterized and are are characterized
in our understood where I'm able to then
sort of treat sort of future patients
another question the question here is in
terms of filtering strategy and
prediction I think creation so
prediction is not one hundred percent
what will be the status of the curation
that's a great point so in terms of the
strategy um the filtering strategy
there's sort of two methods of doing it
one is to do it sort of I know um you're
literally filter and it's no longer in
that next step and some people do that
whereas other people have sort of given
a more sort of evasion approach where
it's throw less likely i'm using
different characteristics and to be able
to do that so the prediction usually is
so using you know mechanisms such as
sort of sift and polyphen where they're
predicting they're predicting
specifically you know how deleterious is
and then it's actually going to be very
different between different algorithms
and income and existing software program
such you know and Anna Barr and other
other program tools are able to actually
to use multiple prediction algorithms
and to be able to see other ones
actually are able to throw leverage
protein structure to say you know
whether it's heavy flow back I drew an
electrophilic and and be able to then
make a sump Shin that you know what if
it's more in the core of a protein it's
sort of more destructive so so the
prediction is not one of a filtering
strategy but then it's to sort of help
understand to be able to help understand
know what of these
potential sort of mutations that are
causing so then when you get to the
curation step a some people are able to
just sort of take the ones that are
critical interiors where other people
are also able to then look at all the
different mutations and say you know
what and even though that this is
predicted to not cause that much effect
but it's in a gene that potentially very
much important so let's sort of dig in a
little bit more in terms of looking at
so those methods will be able to take in
consideration of the different
prediction algorithms to be able to be
able to sort of assess which of the many
of the mutations that exist are the ones
that are causing the phenotype of
interest another question here asking
about are you interested in finding
treatments for single families with rare
gene disorder definitely so we're
genomics was set up specifically to help
families that are unable to be helped by
other mechanisms so scientifically you
know if you think about our setup I rare
genomics it's probably one of them the
worst scientific set up so you think
about right helping single friends is
very very difficult what you want to do
is actually help large families large
cohorts all with the same phenotype and
you know do large projects we will do
that and and the fact is yes a lot of
people are doing that and it's great
that they're doing that and we
definitely think that's sort of the best
efficient use of sort of scientific
funding there however what if you don't
fit into that no you don't fit in these
really large categories and that's when
the single families is going to be
important if they don't have support
structures helping them I'm too and
that's why I sort of a genetics was able
to was we were found it to really help
the people are not being helped and the
family said that may not be sort of as
attractive scientifically then we cooked
these families with the tools so they
can push for themselves first and and to
not only to look for diagnosis but also
look for potential you know the function
of this to create a fearsome cell lines
to create model organisms
the hopes of that it will push this
research far enough that it'll get the
interest of institutions I'll be able to
sort of care this deeper or if you're
really lucky to be able to find
something that you know it's going to be
actionable right away so in terms of
that question we are definitely very
interested in finding single families
with their gene disorders and our big
shift now is there are a lot of families
that already have it done sequencing but
they just you know have gene I don't
know what to do next and maybe that Gina
is not even studied at all line we're in
the middle creating systems and
infrastructure partnering with companies
that contract research organizations and
crowdsourcing to large scientific groups
to be able to to be able to sort of help
these families one by one another
question actual do this question firstly
quickly um someone asking whether
there's a possibility for a postdoctoral
opportunity so right now we are
completely a volunteer-run organization
so if you're sort of interested in sort
of volunteering and time of working so
we have a large number of scientists and
all different aspects of my academia on
postdocs the P is a graduate students
all contributing in different ways so if
you're interested um good leader sort of
email email me and we can go to talk
about what or way you can contribute a
large or small so unfortunately we do
not have sort of post after opportunity
eventually we would hope to have that
but if you're sort of interested in
volunteering more than happy no next
question um whole genome with sequins
whole the whole genome exome sequencing
for a good diagnosis was fight in many
different scientific funds which front
line of this battle will be number one
priority for whole genome sequencing um
yes this is sort of many many different
ways to be able to sort of attack this
and I think right now what's very very
important i think that the algorithms be
able to detect and the call single
nucleotide differences it is pretty much
sort of there yet and so methods to be
able to do with the other types of
sequencing so so those are ways to be
able to do this so which which is what's
what's I think sort of most pressing
here is to have good databases to be
able to serve and annotate the different
clinical mutations so that's going to be
very very important so I think if there
is possibility for large initiatives
were able to collect large amounts of
good exome data and have it be annotated
with good phenotype and genotype
phenotype in sequence and i know and i
think there's international efforts to
be able to do that then at the end of
the day the interpretation is going to
be based on based on the other sequences
are available so for for international
efforts to be able to come together
improvement build those databases
weather isn't someone something similar
to clinvar or others or PGP I think
that's going to be the sort of most
pressing to be able to have you know a
central place for all that annotation to
live and so that you know every single
mutation every single gene what that
sort of is the effect is and then how
we're able to do that google questions
here um question here what is um the jit
neurogenic effects of different disease
hold on one second what is the
neurogenic aspects of different disease
and clinical research c/o whole genome
and axial sequencing can you ignore the
brain in neurons of connectome and
different diseases so so yeah I mean
genome sequencing is only the beginning
right of course and brain disease the
connectome is going to be rare
born in on a cellular level it's that's
going to be important to understand not
just in terms of genetics so there is a
lot of actually advancement in terms of
exome sequencing whether it's mental
illness schizophrenia Parkinson's in
terms of the exome sequencing but this
is one of the many aspects of total
understanding of that disease so um so
yeah so it's important to the look at
other aspects so that's why the
connectome project is going to be a very
very important as well but as a
compliment modality to be able to do
that a few more questions someone asked
in terms of the programs that I'm used
to detect hydrophobicity and I know
whether is hydrophilic um I think the
programming is called chasm CH ASM I
think rachel carson this is a program
that does that but there's there's a lot
of sort of structural prediction of
effectiveness of structural changes
actually how mutations are caused
structural changes and mapping on
existing existing pdb structures and
solve crystal structures to be able to
do that so um so I think the one that
we've used is chasm so it's one of many
many different characteristics to be
able to do that question how many
previous on that those rare diseases
have been assigned to a causal gene
through our GI um yeah no that's a great
question in terms of the difficulty is
um how certain home we know we've lots
of patients in the diagnosis that we
would turn back the question is how many
of the however are we completely sure
that that's gene in and order to be
completely sure probably you know very
very small number but there's ones where
we're almost very certain for example
and it was Robert what happened is you
know it's it's a stop mutation in one
one allele and truncating leave age it's
a truncating and one allele and and one
is sort of inherited from what is the
noble and one sort of nonsense mutation
already that has been inherited so it's
sort of a sort of the classics with a
two-hit there and it's in a gene that
has known to be associated with disease
so that's sort of easier to call however
so Robert you know there's a gnome
disease however let's say rubbers gene
is in another gene that's completely new
which is what the question asker is and
then you know what cellco research is
done so for a fiower feel actually
probably a handful for patients or we're
pretty sure we sort of found something
new we're doing the subsequent
experimental research to be able to put
a valid a pen so yeah I think that this
room an involving number I guess or that
well thank you for more questions and
sort of joining our conference here and
hopefully this is helpful as you sort of
think about um sequencing not only in a
research context within the clinical
contact and figure out ways to able to
help patients with rare diseases again
you have any questions about anything
I'll feel free to email me and I do
working also cancer as well as rare
diseases so happy to be all done and
hopefully we'll be able to sort of work
together to solve all these seven
thousand different diseases a fact I
know the millions of millions of
patients out there unable to help them
one at a time thank you very much
you